I'm probably going to sit down just
because I have notes and just to let you
know that I've been working on this
project about women and interaction
design history for two and a half years
I finished my manuscript in December so
I have not internalized everything yet I
don't have everything memorized but I
wanted to bring some of the stories to
you guys today so
I think it's important to talk about our
history and in looking back at our
history it helps us think about what
we're going to do in the future and next
week is women's History Month starts so
it's a perfect time to do this so let me
set some context first
against the growing disillusionment of
post-war 1950s perfect housewife era we
see in the 60s we start to see second
wave feminism and more and more women
starting to move into the workforce
this started in the 60s and ran for
about a second wave feminism ran for
about 20 years and women were concerned
with equal equality with pay pay Quality
Financial Independence and bodily
autonomy and we see the first group of
women starting to move into the
workforce in large large waves because
they start to be allowed to be
independent earners up until this point
they had part-time jobs they weren't
allowed to have their own bank accounts
they weren't allowed to have credit
cards and then the availability of birth
control facilitated this because people
could start to plan their families and
they could delay marriage and so that's
important to set the background
so
these are just a few dates of things
starting to change when many of the ivy
leaf schools started to allow women into
their classes and into the degree
programs not in the sister schools
so this wasn't that long ago in contrast
Stanford actually allowed women it was
co-educational from the beginning and
offered Advanced degrees to women
starting in 1891. so very Progressive
pardon
um
so despite these dissolving barriers
women were entering tech companies they
were joining the research labs and they
were working as consultants and I've got
a few of these little diagrams which
hopefully are readable but some of the
research facilities and research Labs
were like Bell Labs IBM's Watson lab
Xerox Park Stanford Research Institute
and there were also consultants and I'm
going to talk about one consultant first
Stephanie Rosenbaum
Stephanie Rosenbaum began her career in
technology as a consultant and she
founded her company tech ed in 1967.
her interest in exposure and Technology
came when she participated in a summer
program through the National Science
Foundation and that specific program she
was a part of was spearheaded by
Anthropologist Margaret Mead in 1959 and
they brought together 50 Juniors from
high school working with the computer
scientists and the big IBM 650 and
teaching them for transit in the summer
and when I talked with her she talked
about how exciting I was and really
interesting but that programming was not
going to be for her so that's one of the
things she learned but she realized that
a lot of the people involved in these
programs were going to start computer
companies and they were terrible
communicators
so
she saw her sweet spot and what she
ended up doing was studying language and
philosophy of language at UC Berkeley
and getting her Masters and beginning to
write technical Publications and
computer documentation and then doing
usability and ease of use and ease of
understanding on those documents and
that's how she got into the field and
she is known as a foremother of
usability
she founded her company in Michigan
because that's where her husband was
based and so at this time many many
people couldn't have their own you know
companies they had to be they had to go
where their husbands went their their
knees were second
this actually turned out to be
advantageous because she was in the
Heartland and could test with users that
were not in Silicon Valley she kept an
office here in Silicon Valley to be near
the companies but her the main her main
office with the usability labs are in
Michigan
over the years she got closer and closer
to actual software and less about the
documentation and by the time the web
came about they were act the company was
designing software as well as testing
she got involved in Kai early and with
UPA and began writing articles and
teaching ACI classes and workshops
before there were a lot of programs
there were a few I think CMU existed and
she is still working now 50 years later
she's still working and last year she
got the uxpa Lifetime Achievement Award
and she's a hoot she's pretty funny
so 1974 is the first year a woman could
get a credit card on their own without
their husband or their father co-signing
it wasn't that long ago
um so now I'm going to talk about Park
Xerox Park you may have heard of a few
of these guys on this list but there
were also quite a lot of women who held
phds and they worked were working there
many came in as interns and postdocs to
work including Maryland Tremaine and
Lucy suckman which you may have heard of
her but I'm not going to talk about her
today
so let's I want to talk about first
um actually I'm going to talk about
three women Adele Goldberg Terry Roberts
and and Doris Wells Papa Knox and first
I'm going to talk about Adele Goldberg
and many people list her as a programmer
and a computer scientist and they would
be totally right but I am claiming her
in the early era of interaction design
because of much of the work that she did
straddled ux and design research she got
her PhD in information Sciences at
University of Chicago while she was
working as a research assistant here at
Stanford so there's a lot of people are
going to talk about that have
association with Stanford and she got
involved with a special interest group
with the ACM around education and
working with kids and teaching them
programming and how to use computers and
Allen K from Park heard about her and
recruited her to come work at Park with
him in 1972. and they worked on the Dyna
book together which was one of his
inventions and on Small Talk which he
had created
and
she was instrumental in designing the
user research with kids to test on the
alto and the star and one of the things
they were doing was teaching the
students about object-oriented
programming and how to use that to
create other programs and then testing
that process and iterating she was part
of the team that actually did the demo
of small talk to the Apple folks
and many of you may have heard that
story that Steve Jobs and the Apple
people came in they saw it they stole
the ideas that's actually not true they
didn't steal the ideas they were
Xerox was a a funder they were one of
the investors in apple and part of that
trade was to get a demo of small talk
and the star system and she was part of
that and and did not want to do it she
knew that those guys would totally
understand how things work and would
take it and run and she she you know
resisted and the the corporate folks in
New York basically told her she had to
do it
um so they ordered her to do it and she
was right the The Firm Under The Apple
folks understood how things worked and
it heavily influenced the Macintosh you
know they were already starting that
work but
um
it changed a lot of things with of what
and of course you know the Mac we all
know Max nobody really knows about the
Xerox star
um but one of the things that she also
did was work on the small talk 76 which
led to the work on small talk 80. and
when Alan K left to go to Atari she took
over managing the team
and was responsible for writing a series
of books about small talk 80 including
the book on interface and user interface
and that was a collection of the
components and how they work
and how you would use them together
and defining that and this documentation
is one of the earliest documentation of
user interface way before the human
interface guidelines come out from Apple
and small talk was an object-oriented
language it influenced the gang of four
who wrote the book design patterns which
influenced Jennifer Tidwell who pulled
together her set of interaction design
patterns in designing interfaces which
then influenced the work that I did at
Yahoo and then a whole
slew of interaction design pattern
libraries around there so this is sort
of the early Proto Foundation of that
but it also
was the first overlapping Windows
interface it was one of the first
object-oriented programming languages it
was the first application delivery
system there were a lot of Firsts with
this that hadn't been seen before
integrated multimedia and video
conferencing were all part of the system
that she was driving having worked on
that with Alan K
so 1978 is the first year a woman's job
was protected if they became pregnant up
until that point if a woman got pregnant
she could be fired
and then the pregnancy Discrimination
Act was passed which made a
discrimination by being pregnant part of
the sexual discrimination laws
so the next person I want to talk about
is Terry Roberts
and she came to California
to get her PhD she was looking at
Stanford and she wasn't sure where she
also wanted to kind of do her research
so she looked at Park and she looked at
Stanford Research Institute and she
ended up becoming interested in park
when after Stuart card and Tom Moran
from Carnegie Mellon created their HCI
research lab the research group at Park
and so she worked with them she actually
was the first PhD in HCI here at
Stanford before that degree existed
um and she got that degree in like 78
she worked on her PhD 77 to 78. what oh
it still doesn't exist okay well she got
the first one for something that doesn't
exist there are quite a lot of people
who have it
um so she also worked on the star so
you're going to see the star a couple
more times
um it was a work in progress when she
started so she ended up doing a lot of
usability testing of components and on
the parts and the pieces of interaction
and one of the the things I found
interesting when I spoke with her about
that was she talked about how it
actually didn't succeed and the reasons
why in addition to the hardware being
super super expensive the star was a
closed system so everything happened
within a document the spreadsheets were
inside the document the image editing
was inside a document and that meant
that other developers couldn't come in
and build software to run on the on the
hardware like unlike the Macintosh which
was an open system where outside people
could create software so
um you know in her mind that was
probably part of one of the that was
another reason why it failed and she was
there until 87 when she went to U.S West
in Boulder and US West was one of the
baby bells in the 80s the Bell
corporation was broken up into a whole
bunch of smaller Bell systems because of
what's the uh yes thank you
anti-monopoly and when she went to Bell
she actually was part of the standards
group across the baby bells that
developed working on phone prop systems
and they developed the semantic
structure to reach X press n which I'm
sure you've heard when you've gotten
into a phone tree and that became an
adopted pattern for almost every phone
tree system going forward
so I found that pretty interesting that
you know as an interaction designer and
researcher you were also we don't hear a
lot about voice ux early on that early
she also worked at a variety of other
companies over her career PeopleSoft
into it she was the single designer and
researcher on QuickBooks for accountants
and then she finished out her career at
Tableau working on data cleaning tools
and she when I spoke with her she just
lit up talking about data and working
with data and creating tools for data
but she retired in 2019 and
information about her is really hard to
find and one of the reasons why I
started working on this project is
because people are retiring and their
work is disappearing and if we don't
write it down nobody will know they even
existed
so we don't want that to happen
so 1980 was the year the equal Opera
employment opportunity declared that
sexual harassment on the job was a form
of sexual discrimination
so I thought that was interesting since
that was not that long ago
um but even by the 1980s there were
still companies and universities where
if a woman was offered a job and her
husband worked there she couldn't take
it
they had to work in someplace different
so many women were locked out of places
to work because of where their husbands
worked and I I saw that story over and
over in many of the interviews that I
did yes
yes technically but they're more than
likely they probably would have asked
the woman to leave
just because of the way women were
discriminated against
yeah women in in in these companies
married couples could not work in the
same company
so it it he probably wouldn't have been
offered a job or if it was a different
job or a higher job she probably would
have been asked to leave I don't know
that for a fact though
but good question
um so the next person I'd like to talk
about just very quickly is Doris Wells
papanak she trained at Kansas City Art
Institute with Victor papanak she
studied with him her last name comes
from marrying a distant cousin that she
met way after she studied with him so it
was not like he he introduced her to his
son or something
she started at Park in 83 the same year
that Susan care started at Apple working
on the icon and font designs
um at on the Macintosh
she came to California and was working
and researched and asking her network
where should she work where's the best
place to work and they said Park so she
actually ended up getting hired at Park
and she was the first formerly trained
designer working at Park she was not a
PhD
and she also worked on the star system
so at this point everybody worked on the
star system
um these are some these are not the most
sexy icons but you know we're talking
83. she primarily worked on icons with
another designer named Norm Cox and when
she started only the phds could touch
the computers
so that makes it really hard to do your
work if you can't actually do your work
but she ended up proving herself by
working with the development teams down
in El Segundo which was a group that had
been acquired by Park and all the
developers were down there and so she
went down there and worked with them and
that success created trust up and up
here in Palo Alto
where Park is and
she also brought in this sort of ethos
of design into the group where she would
post things on the in the hallways and
design in public and people could see
what she was doing and that kind of
changed the atmosphere
she left oh did you random question did
you get this image from her because like
the inbox is clearly hers no actually
this I got on Wikimedia
I mean I tried to find the the other
pictures of the star I got from digibarn
which has a whole collection of really
high quality Polaroids of computers with
the star system on it and I've got
permission for that but this is up on
the you know on the internet but yeah
it's totally hers because it says Wells
um yeah
and I was like this perfect she left
Park in 89 went to Apple and joined the
developer side of human interface group
and she also in um
designed the first internet browser that
was called cyberdog which came out seven
years before Safari
so and I don't have a picture that that
I could find royalty free but if you
look up cyberdog a web browser Apple
you'll see it it was kind of like
Netscape it was all encompassing with
mail as well as news and web browsing
and then she left Park in 89 or I said
that already she left Apple in 87 97 and
moved to the Midwest and went back to
school for education and has been using
her user Center design skills to work on
designing and developing new curriculum
for K-12 and then now up into higher
education so she uses her skills but she
doesn't do work in Tech anymore
and she was she was an interesting
person that I talked to So speaking of
Apple so you guys may have heard of some
of these guys
but there were a whole lot of women in
the human interface group and the
Advanced Technology Group I'm kind of
limiting my time limit of here from the
80s early 80s to 92 when Steve Jobs came
back and reorged everything and lots and
lots of people left so I'm going to talk
about three people here Christina Hooper
Woolsey which you guys may have heard of
joy mountford and Sue Booker which you
may not have heard of
so Christina Hooper Woolsey is
considered the mother of multimedia
which is way before the days of the web
so once upon a time we experienced
multimedia on CD-ROMs and it was a hot
that's what I thought I was going to do
when I got out of grad school do
educational CD-ROM multimedia and by the
time I got out and started working the
web came and it killed it so that was a
short-lived goal of mine so Woolsey did
her postdoc work at MIT and she spent 77
and 78 as a visiting professor in the
architecture machine group working with
Nicholas negroponte and she worked on
the Aspen movie project and you guys can
look that up
on the web it was a collaborative team
project that photographed the entire
town of Aspen to create a multimedia
experience of being able to navigate and
fly through the town really like Google
Earth today so today it's not super
impressive but in 1978 it was pretty
freaking amazing it was um according to
her it was exhilarating full of great
people ideas and compelling projects it
was funded by the cybernetics technology
division of DARPA so you know government
funded
we see a few screens from the LaserDisc
it was recorded to LaserDisc and it is
one of the first multimedia titles ever
the screen grabs that I got are from a a
group called domesday 86 and you can
look that up they have
a video of the whole video from the
laser they have a badly damaged copy of
the LaserDisc and they're trying to
restore it but it's pretty interesting
to look at and you know there's some
Stills there were different levels of
this and then here's a picture of a
person sort of sitting in front of the
the projection of the LaserDisc and they
could you know navigate left and right
through the town
um
and it was this was groundbreaking at
the time
so after
MIT she came back to California and was
the research lab director at Atari
working with Alan K and Brenda Laurel
until the company decided to shut down
the research lab because it wasn't
making money because it's a research lab
you know they wanted more of their money
going to making games and so they shut
the lab down and they walked everyone
out and that was in 1984 and she ended
up going to Apple and she worked with
the human interface group doing the
first early definitions of UI elements
like drop downs how did Windows work how
did navigation work and this was right
before the
the Macintosh came out
and
then in 1986 so at this point Steve Jobs
was pushed out he's gone so she founded
a Skunk Works group with another woman
named sueanne ambron who was an
education expert they founded the
multimedia research lab so during this
Heyday we have a whole lot of really
interesting titles coming out of apple
and their goal was to explore multimedia
to explore animation video sound along
with text in the education space and how
could they bring media to help
change how people were learning and for
pretty much every title that they
delivered she was the producer and then
a designer named Christy rosendahl was
the art director who had come over from
the hypercart team
and multimedia it you know they they
ended up exploring all kinds of things
and they also ended up partnering with
companies like lucasfilms and the
Smithsonian and a lot of
organizations that were making content
so they were working on you know how do
we bring these things together in an
interactive environment other people
were providing the content and they
started out in black and white and
eventually you know moved to color much
more interactive as hypercard got more
robust and then as QuickTime came out
the more video stuff
um
so
she was designated a distinguished
scientist in 1985 probably one of the
few women at the time and after the
multimedia lab was shut down in 92 when
jobs came back she did continue in apple
until 97 and worked on a variety of
projects when she left Apple she worked
on this project called visibility do you
remember that okay a couple copies oh
okay well
um basically it was a a multimedia
learning experience it was available
commercially and it was designed to
train people how to see and how to draw
and it was co-created with the designers
Gail Curtis and Scott Kemp and the whole
design system the visual design system
was developed by metadesign and it was
full of videos and workbooks and this
was kind of at the peak and the starting
the beginning of the waning of
multimedia when this came out because I
remember when it came out I was working
on websites
and you know as the multimedia Heyday
waned
um Woolsey moved on to work with other
projects and then eventually at the
Exploratorium and was led the efforts to
move the Exploratorium from the Palace
of Fine Arts down to the Fisherman's
Wharf and she's done other educational
Ventures and she recently self-published
a book about her time in the running the
multimedia research lab so you can get
it on Amazon
which I found really interesting and
then I ended up exchanging emails with
her getting a lot of more information
um
so 1985 by this time half of all college
graduates were women
so we see this increase of women coming
into higher education where earlier they
were going all the way up to getting
phds and by this time
we have you know still many going to get
Advanced degrees but also we have this
uh we start to see people with bfas and
mfas starting to work in in some of
these companies because we're starting
to see some women as managers and
we see a larger group of relevant
disciplines we start to see graphic
design being related and you know the
different psychology social psychology
and cognitive psychology and we have
Scholars from NYU and from MIT and from
CMU coming to work in these different
organizations and Labs you know for
their internships and their research
projects
so the last uh not the last person the
second person that I want to talk about
at Apple is Joy Mumford and
um Joy mountford was at Apple starting
in 1986 but prior to that she began her
career after grad school at Honeywell
and she was working on jet cockpits
space shuttle cockpits she got her
degree in engineering Psychology from
the University of Illinois and she was
doing you know interaction of screens
and heads up display and VR stuff
only when it was only available in
military
situations and she also had to think
about how do toilets work in space so
there was a lot of range of kinds of
things that she was working on because
of the work at Honeywell and when I
spoke with her she's told the story
before that when she interviewed at
Apple
she came home and she cried
because the screen was this big
okay it was only in black and white
there was one keyboard and one Mouse and
you know if you look back look at all
the screens look at all the different
controls
360 degrees because what's up in space
right
and then this but she obviously saw a
promise because she took the job and but
I just think it's funny that she cried
so she ended up man and she came in to
manage the human interface group and
Christina Woolsey told me that they you
know told me about hiring her and um
mountford turned this group from a team
that was documenting and evangelizing UI
components into a Visionary inventive
Powerhouse in and out of the company so
she had a vision that they were not just
going to be the people who documented
how things work for the for the
programmers they were going to do their
own stuff
um so one of the most well-known
inventions that came out of her team and
so this is really really tiny because
that's how tiny QuickTime was when it
first launched was QuickTime they were
they were part of the team that
developed and invented QuickTime
QuickTime VR a whole host of QuickTime
Suites and that was not the only one the
only thing it's just sort of more one of
the most well-known a more recent
invention that you can read about on
Wikipedia is called Stacks or it was
called piles when it first came out that
just came out like three years ago it
was invented back in the 80s by this
group
yeah
yeah I designed any pictures
yeah there's there's all sorts of
stories like that of things that the the
group invented and
um
so the group originally started by Bruce
tognazzini and then first versions of
the human interface guidelines he led
the efforts writing but they were
generally published internally and when
Joy came in one of the things she wanted
to do was get this out because people
were starting to develop software for
the Mac system and if you publish those
guidelines then people will Design to
them and then you have an ecosystem of
software not just what Apple was
creating but what other people were
creating and so that helped raise and
Elevate the reputation of this
organization this other book The Art of
human computer interface design was
conceived by Joy
edited by Brenda Laurel and they it's
just full of essays written by all the
members of of the group many of them
work High papers first that then are in
in the book along with some invited
authors and it still holds up today and
it was printed in 91 or something like
that I have a copy and you read through
it and it's like this could be today it
is still Evergreen so many of the
concepts and ideas hold up
um
so this partly helped create this
landscape of respect and
um you know ability for the group to be
brought in as consultants when the
company was working with outside vendors
and outside customers they helped show
developers how do you do design how do
you test to make sure that your designs
and your interactions are clear and
understandable and how do you prototype
and so all the things they were doing
within the organization using tools like
hypercard to build other tools and using
video and telling and storytelling they
were also teaching to their customers
and people that they worked with
which just spread that across Silicon
Valley
after the reorg at Apple in 92 they
changed the structure and she and
several others went to interval research
one of the other things that she worked
on over time that she started at Apple
was this thing that she called the Expo
where
it was essentially a sponsored Studio
that Apple funded where she would go and
partner with universities but it wasn't
just one University she would generally
have up to eight and have a design
prompt for different groups of students
to be working against and then they
would bring the winner out to Apple to
present to the team and work with the
Apple folks which was pretty cool and
they got some money too and so over the
years as she moved from various
companies working on e-books and big
data and autonomous vehicles she was
able to get all these other companies to
sponsor the Expo and that lasted for 23
years unfortunately the last two
companies she's worked at did not don't
they don't do work with students so this
these pictures are from when Yahoo
sponsored the Expo back when I was there
so and when she was there and you can
see in the black and white picture
that's red burns from NYU talking to Don
Norman and it was crazy stuff so like
the middle one or these little babies
and you know lollipops that as you lick
the babies would move and the faster you
lick the faster they moved I mean it was
just totally weird it was really weird
but you know it was experimental and
exploratory and you know who knows what
would happen with that
and I don't know you know if you have a
group of people doing that you don't
want a second group of people coming up
after them anyway it was a little weird
but it was
the the Expo in and of itself
um allowed joy to work with thousands of
students over these 23 years across the
world and to mentor and you know sort of
spread the word about good design
so the last person from Apple that I
want to talk about is Sue Booker and
um so sue graduated in the mid 80s from
University of Michigan with a degree in
industrial design
but she actually started her job her
first job as an interaction designer
because she'd done her rep her resume on
a Mac and had played around doing some
Max greens and so she ended up being an
interaction designer for the bulk of her
career
she was hired right out of school by
Mill by Bill mogridge at id2 before it
was Ideo and she was the first
interaction designer hired into the firm
she also was like the only one not from
Stanford and um and and the only one not
British so there was a lot of Firsts for
her there and she was the only female
designer in The Firm for a while
and one of their clients was Park and so
she got to spend a whole lot of time at
Park and ended up working with Bill
Plank and collaborating with him and
then they poached him over into id2 but
she got to work on things like
interactive whiteboards and and
um
sort of crazy stuff that has never been
been invented and she actually
overlapped with Doris Wells popping out
because Doris mentioned that and then
one of their other clients was Apple and
in that process of working with apple
she ended up getting post away to Apple
and she went to go work on this the
Newton so this was the first tablet that
came out of apple didn't last very long
it wasn't super successful but when she
started it was a Skunk Works project she
was the lead designer and she was able
to do all sorts of research she followed
people around watched them how did they
exchange business cards because the
concept was this was going to replace
daytimers was going to replace the the
exchange of business cards and
one of the other things she got to do
was Commission the the ideas for the
industrial design from companies around
the us as well as in Italy she also got
to go to Japan and this is sort of an
interesting story is she went to Japan
to talk with the folks making the
touchscreen technology or the screen
technology because this uses stylus but
I think at the time they were thinking
about touch screen and they didn't know
what to do with her when she arrived
because they'd never had a woman come
talking to the business people and
needing to go into the clean room so
they had no place for her to change into
that little bunny suit to go into the
clean room and she was telling me that
she ended up being taken aside by the
ladies who made tea and changing where
they make the tea so it's like not you
know it's not sterile but it was because
they just didn't work with women
and you know she's got all sorts of
sketches she kept all her sketchbooks
from this time but it was pretty Petty
time in terms of you know working on
this thing that wasn't a real project
yet kind of being able to Blue Sky Go
any direction and she was telling me
that the industrial designers inside
Apple were actually pretty threatened by
what was happening because they were not
part of it it was not a a program yet
and there was another project happening
in the Advanced Technology Group
around a tablet that was being done and
so Larry Tessler came over from that
group to check out what was happening in
the Newton thought what was going on was
better and so he killed the other
project and then this became a real
project which means they got a product
manager and now they had to you know
really think about the real industrial
design and by this time if you read the
stories the I the thing was huge it was
probably like the giant big iPads that
we have today is what the form factor
was going to be and it was going to cost
something like ten thousand dollars
which you know back then was kind of
outrageous for a tablet so John Scully
came into their team and said it's got
to fit in my pocket
and so they ran around looking for foam
core cutting them down to fit in his
pocket and she told me like it was
really good thing he had a big pocket
because the the device I don't you know
is about was about this big and it was
about that thick so yeah it was a huge
pocket it was it was uh it was not a
small thing when it came out and um I
had a friend when I was working at a
startup who had one because he really
liked the the touch screen or the device
but a lot of the concepts and things
that she designed just like I talked
about things that were happening in the
human interface group that didn't show
up until a couple years ago like she
developed and designed that paper
crumple and the swoosh when you trash
things that you see in the computer and
iPad now she designed that for the
Newton in the 80s and they're only now
getting implemented so all kinds of so
she has all sorts of patents around that
kind of stuff
um she left Apple worked all around the
valley I met her I knew her at Yahoo but
she went back to Apple about a dozen
years ago spent the last Dozen Years of
her career becoming an expert in voice
accessibility and working on Siri and
she was one of the only people in the
company besides who specialized in that
and she spent the last part of her
career on that and she retired in 2021
so again another person retiring
so a discussion of graphical user
interfaces and these um
platforms and and the companies creating
the computers can't we can't not talk
about Microsoft there's not as many
women that I can find in Microsoft but I
am going to talk about two
Virginia Howlett and Mary Deeley
really hard to find information about
these folks so Virginia Hallett joined
Microsoft in 1985 as a graphic designer
she was working in marketing working on
print stuff and she wrote Bill Gates a
letter in 1987 describing the importance
of why design and software
was a competitive advantage
and I think it was because she was
seeing how popular and um and how
successful the Macintosh was you know
having all those designers working on
things so that letter worked and she
became a founding member and UI designer
for the user interface architecture
group at Microsoft and uh the team was
her Mary Deeley running usability
research and Tandy Trower as the PM
she worked on and launched Windows 30 of
which the icons were designed by Susan
care because she had left Apple by then
and then she also worked was the lead
designer on Windows 95 which according
to Legend is was the most heavily user
tested product in Microsoft history
um and that aligns with the usability
labs coming online
in another project that she worked on
she worked with type designer Matthew
Carter and directed the project for the
new typefaces
you know having come from graphic design
she saw like we need better type for
screen design we need type that can be
scalable and that will look good small
so they ended up with verdana which is
what's on the left and it is partially
named after her daughter Anna and then
she continued working with him on the
serif font Georgia which was
specifically designed for screen use and
there are a couple other fonts Tahoma I
think is another one that which is
verdonna compressed and others that were
part of the suite and the suite was
available on Microsoft Windows but also
on the Mac it was released out and then
she left the company and retired and she
has spent the rest of her time as a
painter and an educator so she is not
intact she's really hard to find except
you can find her paintings
um the last Microsoft person is Mary
Dealey and she received her PhD in
rhetoric from Carnegie Mellon and did
deep work in the usability of documents
just like Stephanie Rosenbaum did that's
how she started and Jenny reddish who
I'm not talking about today also started
her career doing usability testing of
documentation and then realizing that
easy to read documentation isn't going
to help hard to use software
um so she started at Apple in the early
80s helping user test the Lisa and that
was while she was in grad school working
with another woman named Ellen nold and
she was at Adobe prior to Microsoft and
I don't know exactly how long
um she came in to Microsoft around the
time of the windows 3 release and then
joined to become the lead usability
person for the user interface
architecture group and she founded the
first two usability Labs at Microsoft
and designed them and led them the
construction of those and she was
instrumental in getting usability
testing into the software development
cycle at Microsoft she authored a ton of
papers there's a lot of chi papers about
about this there are also lots of papers
that cite her work on how to set up Labs
how to integrate testing into the
product development process we take that
for granted nowadays but back then that
was just not done and you know nobody
had labs and and so she was essentially
the leading expert on integrating
usability practices into these product
processes and she left Microsoft after
that Windows 95 push and worked with
companies like Netscape and Cisco and HP
and unfortunately she died in 2002 so
her career was not super long
so I can't
um so one of the things I want to
acknowledge is sort of an elephant in
the room is that if you've noticed all
the people I've talked about so far are
white
and part of that comes from the fact
that at this point we're expecting women
to have phds and the number of women
graduating with phds during this time
was very low compared to men and the
number of people of color graduating
with phds at this time was even lower
yes so
is a journal degree so well only one was
only a couple were Masters but even
other people who haven't talked about
had phds and just there weren't
um because they weren't being hired at
the Master's level they were being hired
at the PHD level in these early early
days
on the west coast but on the East Coast
thing there were things happening with
larger companies that were adding Tech
that had a longer history of hiring
diverse workforces so I'm going to talk
about three people quickly
Carol Bilson Sylvia Harris and Valerie
Fenster and this work most was all being
done on the East Coast
um so Carol Bilson she has a
undergraduate degree in industrial
engineering from University of Michigan
trained as an industrial designer and
graphic designer and she started at
Kodak in 1980 she was the first
African-American designer in the company
she founded support groups and
networking groups for African-American
employees and black women at the company
and she moved from design to product
management eventually becoming a general
manager that's your path
and she ended up running several
programs but the most successful was the
picture maker division which brought in
over 80 million dollars into the company
through the time that she ran that
program and just I worked on that when I
worked at Kodak right after grad school
and I worked on stuff you know you could
go in bring in a picture lay it down get
enlargements get repeats put in your you
know eventually with digital cameras put
in your flash cards get pictures these
were all over you know drugstores and
Target and Walmart and stuff so it was
very very successful
she left Kodak after 20 years went to
head up ued at Pitney Bowes and then was
promoted to VP of global design and
usability which made her the first
African-American to head up a business
division in corporate us at the time
and then in 2014 she became president of
the design Management Institute which is
a think tank and Research Institute
primarily working with Fortune 500s but
one of the interesting things that is
during her time there they released the
results of the of a design value index
that they had been tracking so they
brought in researchers and this started
before she went in there before she
started but they looked at Fortune 500
companies with c-level design
people
and track them from 2005 to 2015 against
the S P 500 so they had a list of about
10 or 15 companies
and over the 10 years those companies
outperformed the S P 500 by 211 percent
it's pretty interesting you know so
that's the design value index it's not
being tracked anymore they stopped it in
2015.
so the last two people I want to talk
about
are Sylvia Harris and Valerie Fenster
and um so in 1983 the minitel which I
don't know if you guys you've heard of
it so the mini tell was this dumb
terminal that was given to every
household in France and it was intended
to replace the Yellow Pages and phone
books and it wiped out Yellow Pages and
Yellow Page advertising in France and at
the time Valerie Fenster was working at
Ketchum advertising in Chicago and was
handling the clients and their Yellow
Page advertising accounts and she was
charged to become an expert in
e-commerce
and tools like the mini toe to
understand how they worked and how
advertisers could become part of that
directory an explosion you know and
exploring how that could be used here in
the US so she got her start kind of
learning about e-commerce
in the mid 80s so she was working with
Sylvia Harris and Sylvia Harris Let's go
back is on the left and Valerie Fenster
is on the right
left right so I double check there for a
second
Harris was working with her doing some
print work and she was a partner in a
consulting firm called 212 Associates
that she and two of her classmates from
Yale School of Design had founded
and Sylvia Harris's early career she was
working on things like video texts and
UI for Prodigy and one of their clients
was Citibank and they had this opening
for someone to come in and Lead
interaction design and usability testing
and she told Valerie Fenster about it
Valerie got the job and so she became
Sylvia's client so they collaborated
together for several years on designing
UI for the ATMs and this was when the
ATMs were switching over from ASCII text
to touch screen
and this is a picture of their ghost
Branch so this is a usability lab that
is in that was in a building in
Manhattan in the basement where they
could set it up and rearrange and do
other things and bring in people to test
their their prototypes so during this
time Finster would do the interaction
design and do set up all the testing and
Sylvia worked on the wireframes and all
the UI
and um
this is an early early mock-up of uh one
of the screens it's really like low low
foots this is so old school it's just
too funny
um but they worked together for a long
time on all sorts of banking products
different tools checking savings
accounts depositing checks all these
things that we think are really sort of
passe today that wasn't being done
people were scared to put a check in
they were scared to move money
um you know they really just wanted to
check their balance and get some cash
so they worked together they would build
these prototypes put them they've had
some developers that worked with them to
put them on the actual ATM machines and
they worked that way for a while until
trying to get ready for some testing
late at night as you do
things overheated and kind of exploded
and next you know she's that sorry I
talked with Valerie and she was like no
then I switched to building things in
hypercard and Faking It on the Macintosh
because of the the ATM machines were so
fickle to build prototypes on it was
kind of silly one of the interesting
things is in 1990 the American
Disabilities Act passed and City took
the lead on developing an ADA Compliant
ATM and there's two screens here there's
there's the deposit touch screen and the
the main touch screen and the deposit
withdraw touch screen and so they
prototyped all different kinds of things
and then they brought in
um blind and low site folks one of the
designers that worked at 212 he's
actually here in the Bay Area and I
talked with him he said you know people
are coming in where they're seeing eye
dogs and and they learned a lot they
learned that white on black was better
for low sight than black on white
because of the Shimmer and the visual
issues that happened with the vibration
of of the black of the white background
and so this particular ATM launched it
no longer exists it was written up by ID
magazine in 1993 that magazine no longer
exists so and it also was part of a Kai
panel in 94.
because they're slightly different or is
it the same I actually don't know I mean
I think there's probably because the
white is backlit and it does cause a
visual vibration it probably still has
the same issues I don't know that for a
fact they'd have to do it's probably
some biological scientific research on
that I know I get ocular migraines when
I spend too much time looking at White
screens versus the darker screens
uh I don't know yeah but that's a good
question
and um so after this project Sylvia kind
of left her firm and was exploring her
work as an African-American designer she
was writing essays about being an
African-American designer and what that
meant and after this point then she got
involved with the 2000 census and ever
all of her work after that was around
Civic and policy design and she died in
2011 unfortunately but she brought
user-centered design practices into
print design
and she was one of the first people to
do that and Valerie Finster went on to
get a master's degree in human factors
um ended up doing some work with Bank of
America on AOL and is now doing
Healthcare devices and she was telling
me it's so much harder to design work
that has to go through FDA than work
that you know Financial work but she's
still working and finally 1993 is the
year that maternity leave is finally
protected up until this point if you got
pregnant you couldn't get fired but if
you left to go on maternity leave there
was no guarantee your job would be there
when you got back
so with this law passing and the
emergence of the World Wide Web as a
Communications vehicle and a viable
design opportunity we have a sea change
shift in and we see the emergence of
third wave feminism we see the highest
numbers of women graduating from college
and we see a growing number of women
entering technology including
interaction design because of the
opportunities afforded by web design and
Webb it was so easy and we see people
coming from all disciplines into this
space and it changed everything but
that's another story so thank you
thank you
questions
oh Mikes yeah
and thanks for the questions in in line
I really appreciate that
um so you alluded to this throughout the
talk about like the difficulty of
tracking down this information but I was
wondering if you could talk a little
more about like what you had to do to
find these people like it sounds like
some of it you you knew through
connections but like
places I started with my connections
just because I'm old and I've been
working for a long time and I figured if
I know people I might as well start with
them
um many of the people I started with
though were sort of starting with the
90s and with the web and then I kind of
asked people who else I should be
talking to I also did lots of research
I read and I trolled the citation lists
uh bibliographies and citations in a ton
of books of Silicon Valley Tech History
you know around Xerox park around Apple
you know about the tech not necessarily
just looking for names of women who
might have been working at the company
that I then could look up
um I spent a lot of time in the Wayback
machine looking at in so much from the
mid-web days is gone because Flash you
know people building things in flash it
doesn't exist and then people led me to
people so I I interviewed a couple of
the women who started founded Kai I
interviewed people who were doing things
in the mid 90s and doing conferences and
and
um you know so it's like and I also put
out on social media and said if you were
going to read a book about women in
interaction design history who should be
on there and I have a list of turns out
hundreds and hundreds of women many
who've never heard of
um and I just ended up
kind of selecting based on you know can
I find
their information can I find them I
interviewed 45 people
um in person and you know on zoom and
they led me to other people but like
Terry Roberts I basically interviewed
her in November and I had to finish my
manuscript in December by December 1st
like I didn't find her and it turns out
we have people in common that we know
but I just didn't realize I think I read
something and I wasn't sure she was
female because everything was Terry and
Terry could go either way and it wasn't
until there was a mention of her oh I
found Doris uh well as Papa knock and
then she mentioned Terry and I'm like
wait a minute and so then I looked her
up on LinkedIn I'm like oh we have these
people in common so I reached out to
those people and said could you please
introduce me to her and it took a while
to get her because she was on vacation
because she's retired you know she just
doesn't care about any of this and then
I was able to interview her and
um so it I started working on this two
and a half years ago because as I was
teaching a history class same time
Christina was teaching and we were
trading names
and then I just kind of it just kind of
ballooned and there's so many people
that need their stories told you know
even if it's just you know sort of feels
mundane today but at the time they were
you know they were the first and it's
not always good to be the first but
somebody has to be first
um and you know so like with joy
mountford one of the things with her she
hired lots and lots of people not like
her she hired writers she had artists
she hired uh designers you know she
comes from engineering psychology and
she always made sure there was at least
one woman on every team
and so it takes someone proactive like
that to bring more people into the fold
and it has to be concerted and
thoughtful but yeah I have lists and
lists and then when I got I got feedback
on my original proposal and sample
chapters I was given a list of a whole
bunch of other people from Academia and
I'm like I can't I can't do that too
have to have boundaries but there are so
many people working on so many really
interesting amazing projects right now
it's and in the past in the academic
spaces I mean that's just like a whole
other
library of encyclopedia
so hopefully that answered your question
I'm curious
um you know you titled The Talk The Lost
women of ixd I'm curious if you flip
that bit the non-lost like the ones who
you think get do you think they're all
lost do you think they are like some who
you intentionally didn't include I'd be
curious like who are some of the role
models for you who are kind of
so I didn't include Brenda Laurel it was
probably one of the most well-known or
written about people because she has
been written about so much both as a
game designer and an interaction
designer
um I talk about her in the book you
can't not talk about her but I don't
profile her because there's the whole
book's written about her
um I barely talk about Susan carer
because there's lots and lots and stuff
but you got to talk a little bit about
UI design and
um who else do I not talk about
I ended up so I in in the stuff that I
wrote I wrote way too much I had to cut
35 people from my manuscript and one of
the people I cut some of the decisions
were how well known is this person so
like Karen Hansen who is one of the was
one of she's a design leader at the
global X you know CX level
um and she's very well known and there's
been a lot written about her because of
her work and Intuit and and working with
Brad Smith an infusing design for
Delight through the company so
I kept some quotes from her but I ended
up cutting her because there's a lot you
can just put in her name and you get you
know pages of stuff about her but I
started with her because I know her so
um but she gave me names of other people
to talk to
um who else did I not I
yeah I I don't go as far back like I
yeah no I think that's Prime primarily
Brenda Laura brindle Laurel's probably
the most well-known person that I don't
talk about I ended up cutting like Terry
Irwin and some systems folks and
um
yeah
so um
do you have any theories from your
conversation with all these women about
why so many women have gotten lost in
these conversations people who are
probably shouldered shoulder with a Don
Norman or equally well-known people I
have theories and I um
one we we the big we women you know not
all women but women we are not as good
at self-promotion because we're team
players
interaction design is a team sport and I
think that's you know who wants to take
credit for something when it was all of
you that worked on it
but many guys do and and you know not
default them but they're much better at
promoting themselves and their work than
women are just I mean that's a
generalization but I think that's part
of it is because we're not out there
talking about all the great stuff we did
and uh we're not writing about it we're
not showing it off as much as the men
because we believe in that collaboration
and it's to take that Village so I think
that's a big reason why and then a lot
of these women yes they were like really
focused on their work
but they're retired now and they you
know and they were pre-web pre-blogging
pre-sharing on social media and so they
just didn't have the venues other than a
Kai paper here or there to get even
information about their workout and so I
think that's another reason why a lot of
those earlier people are we just don't
hear their names very much because
they're the the opportunities and the
and the channels for broadcasting about
themselves didn't exist
well I think if there aren't any more
questions then um people should go eat
thank you very much can we have one more
thank you Aaron